-Everyone, I know that people
find math boring.
A lot of people. Yeah.
Well, that's why we have updated
math to make the equations
about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
♪♪
♪ Popular Mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Love that song.
-I think that should be
a hit song.
I love that.
Can we just...
Yeah, one more time.
♪♪
♪ Popular Mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Yeah. Levels, levels!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The levels are genius.
Love it.
-Nice.
-Let's take a look at
our first equation here.
If you take Babe Ruth
plus becoming a father,
it equals
Daddy Yankee.
You see what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Here's another one here.
Llamas --
-Llamas.
-Plus a blow out
equals Alpacas.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
If you take an activity none
of your friends want to do,
plus 15% off,
it equals Groupon.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Wanna go?
-We're going to bungee jumping.
We're going bungee jumping.
-I got a coupon.
-It's real cheap.
-Getting eye surgery?
I got a coupon.
-Cheap, cheap --
cheap laser eye surgery.
Here's another one here.
Mermaids --
-Yep.
-Plus throwing gang signs
equals the Starbucks logo.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-If you take a priest
plus hay, it equals
Christian Bale.
[ Light laughter ]
I can feel -- I'm getting
smarter just by doing this.
-You can feel it, yeah.
-Here's another one here.
A pit in the ground, plus water,
times three,
plus being confused equals
"Well, well, well,
what do we have here?"
[ Laughter ]
-What?
I get the "Well, well, well --
-That's a thinker.
That's a thinker.
-What's the "what do
we have here?"
[ Light laughter ]
-What was it again?
-Yeah, it was three holes
with water --
-Yeah, that's
"Well, well, well."
-There's "Well, well, well."
But you're saying that
"What do we have here?"
Is being confused?
-Yeah, that's being confused.
-Oh, OK.
-What do we have here?
Yeah, exactly.
-Common phrases Americans use
to -- [ Laughs ]
-Being confused.
-Yeah, yeah.
What do we have -- [ Laughs ]
-If I had a nickel for
every time I said that today.
-Oh, my God. Yeah, today
I've said that like, 60 times.
[ Light laughter ]
-What do we have here?
Very famous.
[ Light laughter ]
Finally, if you take
Edward Scissorhands
plus giving a sheep a haircut,
it equals Ed Sheeran.
There you go, everybody.
That's all the time we have for
"Popular Mathematics."